you know i've seen the videos of elon
talking about
um he wanted education to be
problem focused rather than tool focused
right so i was like what is that is that
the
is that is that what led to
you know you creating synthesis for the
school and i was kind of kind of walked
me through that i never asked him that
story like from you know to tell me that
the whole way through before and so he
was like yeah we i was i was at this
other school you know teaching elon's
kids and he would come in for like you
know parent-teacher conferences and it's
like you know he's he's elon musk i
didn't think he would want to talk about
like normal stuff parents wanted to talk
about at conferences and so i showed him
this thing this goldilocks exercise i
had the kids do which was basically
you give the kids a trillion dollars in
hypothetical money
and you give them a couple sectors in
the in the economy or in the world to
allocate it and you just ask like how do
you want to allocate the money do you
want to you know conserve like you know
endangered species habitats do you want
to invest in health care education like
how do you want to invest this money and
like elon thought it was pretty cool and
so then when i wanted to start the
school he's like you know came to me it
was like you know remember remember this
teacher is kind of like aligned with
what i want to do
and so then
now he's like reporting to elon he's the
only teacher in the world reporting to
elon musk and it's pretty intense right
because you want to you want to keep
your job and you're just every meeting
you're just like constantly worried that
you're going to get fired and so
he knows kind of elon's dictators like
you teach kids how to solve problems
which he takes he's like well elon's the
world's best problem solver let me like
observe him when i'm in the meetings
with him
and
he's watching and the interesting thing
is like
he's elon has incredible command of the
details on a lot of things that have to
do with the rockets material science
like that that kind of stuff he knows
just incredibly well when he's meeting
with josh he's running the school he
doesn't have the full context like josh
knows the details more than he does
and so josh is realizing he's coming to
these meetings josh is kind of telling
him what's going on with the school
and he he lacks the context but he's
gotten really good at auditing your
reasoning communicating what he wants
and and communicating with you to like
figure out the course corrections so
he's doing you strip away all the
context and he's still got some skill
of thinking and problem solving even
without the command of the details and
so josh is observing this and he's
thinking
you know that's really interesting how
can i get kids to do this because the
normal way in school is you'll do like a
whole
unit where you learn you know about
everything you do all this like
knowledge gathering and then you'll do a
project like at the end and he's like
that's pretty like time-consuming and
you can see like elon's doing this thing
where he doesn't need all that
information he can just like kind of
reason from first principles and so josh
starts giving the kids these problems
where he strips away a lot of the
context so it's like
he started asking them
a question spacex dealing with at the
time how would you move the company to
brownsville texas and the kids are they
get really into that right they come up
with all these plans and and they get
really excited by it and you know
they're really really like learning to
think and to communicate with edge of
the other to form these plans
but
when you get to the end of it it's like
cool good plan and then that's it right
you just like throw it away there's no
there's no action there's no feedback
and so from that he started making these
you know turning these kind of questions
into simulations where you're competing
with the other teams and now there's a
reality now you can do the iterative
feedback loops now there's like there's
emotional stakes right so before when
it's just a question it's like
cognitively interesting but you know in
the real world you need to actually make
decisions you need to see how things
turn out you need to course correct and
that's how that's how we arrived at you
know the full suite that is synthesis
this is fascinating because
when i was at facebook
at one point
the interview process would essentially
allow for uh product managers to
interview potential product managers
that were coming into the business and
the way that we did it was uh they would
go through some screening and filtering
but then there was three people uh that
were current product managers that would
each take a specific track so you're
gonna focus on like product uh
development i'm gonna focus on like
execution and teamwork and somebody else
may focus on like cultural fit or
something right
and you go into the interview and it's
just one on one with the individual but
you know i'm here to specifically get at
this angle for right for the interview
process and the one that i uh spent the
most time learning about uh and
eventually ended up doing you know over
100 interviews at the company with
candidates around was
giving them a hypothetical situation and
then basically continuously feeding them
more and more information to see how
they thought through the problem so i
have no clue that any this is going on
first time uh that i'm hearing some of
these details and i learned this from
some of the product managers at facebook
who are very good interviewing people
and the example i would always use is
like hey you
come in to work on friday everything's
fine you have a great day at work you go
home friday night you come back monday
morning and 50 of the traffic to your
product has disappeared what do you do
and it's fascinating because what it got
at was i always remember the best answer
i ever had was
somebody who had been doing this for 15
years
first thing they said was i would
immediately alert everyone on the team
that we have a problem
everyone would just jump to solve the
problem but somebody who had done it
before is like communicating more more
brains on the problem exactly so like
little things like that you pick up on
like okay this person knows what they're
doing versus somebody who just tries to
jump at it and as you would work through
the problem you basically tell them more
okay uh they would say i would go and i
would check the dashboards fine when you
check the dashboard you see that uh no
traffic has dropped off from these three
platforms and you just kind of keep
giving it more more information and
eventually like it would end up with
like uh we would get on the phone with
google and ask them why our links are
broken or you know whatever yeah
and you really really got a good sense
for how somebody thought what they would
do in that situation even though it's
just two people sitting in a room
talking about a hypothetical yeah it
sounds like that's really similar
actually to what elon and josh figured
out with the school and synthesis as a
class specifically was just doing that
but doing it for kids rather than
waiting until you're you know 20 30 is
40 years old to try to put you in that
situation
yeah yeah completely and i think it's
really strange like i know people who
have been to
been to law school people who worked at
mckinsey it's like consulting firm where
they they're really like you kind of
teach you this rigorous thought process
you know obviously uh and then computer
programmers i feel like computer
programming is where i learn to think
and reason
properly because you're just you just
come face to face with the results of
your sloppy thinking right and that's uh
that's what synthesis does for kids like
it it's you know if you if you do this
thing in school like the kind of like
the previous
you know the iteration the step like
right before we got to synthesis is like
you know plan something out like make a
plan do do what you're doing in like the
facebook interviews but it's it's just
kind of like sterile to do that right
because you need that feedback from the
environment so when you're learning to
like program you know you get that
feedback and it's like it's brutal like
shows you how sloppy your thinking is if
you're in law school you know you've got
to argue with other people and so you'll
get eviscerated if you don't do it
properly in school like i'm not sure
where kids ever get that experience and
the test that you come up against in
school
is just like did you spit the
information
back or you know did you kind of repeat
the teachers opinions back to them and
what's nice about the way you do it in
synthesis it's kind of
it's like it's combat for your for your
mind and you know it's a team sports
it's team combat which is the way that
the world
actually works and you know it just
takes the teacher
out of it it's not like if we're saying
this is bad work it's like it's not our
opinion like you just you just got
destroyed in this game and that's it's
really cool to see that like the kids
that come in who are the smart kids like
the gifted kids
you know they get smashed that first
time and they always come in they're
super
super confident like we're gonna crush
everybody because i always get the best
grades on the tests in school and so
they got this plan they go into battle
and they get crushed and you know
they'll start crying a lot of times but
then you they'll come back
and because it's that you know it's that
ego you know just like just just
humbling yourself and i think it's
really good to get that experience early
because then you just kind of you shut
off the part of you that's like i just
need i need approval i'm just going to
get like the grades and the gold stars
and everything and you start worrying
about like how to actually improve
yourself and improve your thinking
is intellectual humility like a key
foundational component of
being able to think clearly like do the
kid have to get to that point and it's
almost like it's kind of like military
boot camp like you get to break them
down before you build them back up to
some degree yeah yeah i think that's
right i think it's always like one of
the things that most admired about elon
is the way he talked about his projects
like early on it's like i don't
don't really think these things are
necessarily going to work but they're
worth trying and i think that's it's
just really important to keep that
mindset and if you read a lot of history
you know
and people who get killed are often like
the most arrogant about their prospects
and the generals that that survive and
keep winning are the ones who are always
worried about losing and so yeah you
want to get that i i know i i like
graduated from school and like went out
and like started businesses and just got
killed like i just did not realize what
an idiot i was and i had to learn the
hard way and like cost a lot of money
and just made a lot of long-term you
know a lot of mistakes and i think you
know the hope with synthesis is that you
can
you know i really think the problem is
in school you just don't get to act
right like you're not a you're not an
agent you're like a passive kind of
receptacle of information and there's
some value of that like we all need to
learn arithmetic and we learn how to
read and there's some basic information
we need to know but yeah i think we kind
of stretch out school and make
what could be learned in you know one or
two hours a week we just we just stretch
it out you know for eight hours a day
just because we have to fill the time
and uh you know what synthesis does it
gives kids a chance to be
be an agent it's like you know mental
combat it's fun it's like a team sport
for sharpening your thinking and
sharpening your communications hey guys
thanks so much for watching that clip of
the best business show make sure you
like and subscribe to the channel turn
on notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it
you